let me ask you this because you brought
it up and I know you probably don't
watch because it's trendy and popular
Mr Belvedere did you see have you seen
the Mandalorian episode with lizzo
absolutely I just watched that the other
day I was going to bring that up yeah
yeah because you know it's cool it's
he's the cool kid that doesn't watch
anything that everyone else is watching
so all right if Taco Taco knows this
about me I have not spent one second
with like Star Trek and Star Wars I just
can't do it it's not for me
yes it does no it's 100 you being cool
kid what do you think Taco all right
don't do well with the space stuff I
don't do well with space stuff and
fantasy things I'm sorry
well then let me talk about space I
would love for you too lizzo was in
there she was a guest
okay she was a guest with uh Jack Black
they played like a king and queen and uh
lizzo I love lizzo she's not the most
experienced actor
she was kind of like looked like she was
reading her lines yeah kind of off
screen I love Mandalorian I thought it
was a little it's a cartoony show 100
but I thought it was a little too
cartoony but I did want to ask about it
because you know yeah they and then they
shoved Christopher Lloyd in there out of
no out of nowhere you're like okay uh
yeah so in one episode they've got lizzo
Christopher Lloyd and Jack Black all
guest starring yeah
what is Jack Black doing on this show he
was playing he was the uh uh he was a he
was like I think it was a king of a
planet and uh he and lizzo were in love
so they were the like the king and queen
well that's how you know it's realistic
yes just like in real life yeah Liz
those are queen Jack Black is our king
um it was like a detective episode it
was almost like watching an episode of
uh
CSI Miami or something you know because
it was like there's a mystery and I
gotta go talk to people and solve the
mystery and yeah you know then and then
it was almost scooby-dooish I don't know
if I should spoil it but you know like
the
endless Guy this is ripped off at the
end
if it weren't for these awful kids we
would
interesting I had no idea that's why I
brought it up fun little episode yeah
yeah it was a big surprise you're right
Christopher Lloyd I forgot about that
yeah
Christopher Lloyd was he uh any sort of
like by the way I'm excited about
um the Chris talk about Christopher
Lloyd because it allows me to talk about
Back to the Future ever ever it's my
favorite movie of all time uh but uh
they're about doing they're about to do
a back to the future play on Broadway
here and every now and then I keep
getting pictures of random Christopher
Lloyd sightings in the city and all
every time it's just like crazy old man
walks down street it like it looks like
the weirdest uh like in the wild
Christopher Lloyd moment that you can
find God I love him
yeah see that's so funny
um that's a Zeitgeist thing I've heard a
lot of people your age that love back
back to the future I liked it it's not
that movie for me so but that's a that's
an age thing yeah I love it and honestly
the story of how it was made is just as
fascinating as the movie really yeah
when you realize that it was like they
did half the movie without uh what's his
name and they did a whole another movie
without him and then they had to start
it all over again when they fired the
first actor yeah uh Eric Stoltz Eric
Stoltz that's right and they shot like
60 to 80 percent of it with Eric Stoltz
and then they they said yeah this isn't
working and then watching some of those
clips back watching some of those clips
back you're like you're right this
doesn't work this sucks
um oh yeah yeah
uh interesting no so that would the
Mandalorian thing would have gone right
past me but I'm glad we covered it uh in
such fine fashion here on the what
podcast
really glad we dug deep that's where
people come to talk live up lizzo and
Star Wars uh franchise yeah
we'll talk about a battle star Galactic
Boba Fett yeah
Blasio suffered greatly under Imperial
rule my husband came here as part of his
Rehabilitation he fell in love
[Music]